life is returning to Wuhan with trains
allowed to enter half a dozen subway
lines reopening and the buses up and
running again but once people arrive at
Wuhan station they haven't made it yet
first they need to register at the
health reception points a green code on
a mobile app shows whether they are
considered to be healthy trains had been
fully booked in advance for many people
is the first chance to see the loved
ones again
after months of lockdown this young man
meets his mother again for the first
time in three months associates I guess
it makes me very happy to see my family
my mother said we wanted to hug but
these are special circumstances so we
can't hug or anything like that the
epidemic situation in China has taken a
turn for the better but it has not been
completely destroyed staff at Wuhan
station did not take any risks
they all wear full protective gear they
are paying special attention to people
who are returning from overseas
particularly as infections are
increasing abroad I think the resumption
of work represents a kind of hope it at
least shows that china is victorious i
saw news on the train that china is now
sealing off its borders i think it's a
requirement needed for us to return to
work according to official statistics
only one new case has been reported in
the past week but until the 8th of april
Wuhan remains a one-way street only then
will restrictions be lifted for people
wanting to leave the city alright let's
bring in Fabien Kretchmer he joins us
now from Beijing Fabien Wuhan this is
really where the the pandemic first
emerged millions of people there were
put in a total lockdown what's life like
there now with these restrictions
starting to be lifted
well I guess you cannot call it normal
bit but what is actually normal these
days anyway but compared to the previous
week's get some streets are filling up
with people and people are going
shopping also enjoying the new freedom I
mean for for several weeks they haven't
been allowed to just leave their
residential compounds so yes also bus
routes are operating again subways are
surprised crowded as well but it's only
a partial opening up of the city and the
people are not are the residents of
mahon are not allowed yet to leave the
city but people are allowed to enter the
city and when they enter that at the
train stations they have to prove that
they're healthy and they do that with a
smartphone QR code that they scan and a
green code means that they're healthy
that means they have been tested before
and have not been in contact with anyone
yeah infected or who had contact to a
confirmed case I've been given these
controls that are still in place I mean
there must still be fears that like in
some other countries in Asia there could
be a second wave of infections within
the country we know that people in Hebei
province who are living in the province
who bathe it's a province surrounding of
Wuhan and they have been hold back by
the residents of other provinces really
at the borders and even police men
fighting them to hold the residents back
that's because and people are afraid of
the people who way and studies have
shown that if China eases those
regulations too fast the second wave
will occur reoccur and the problem is
China does not count as some tomato
cases meaning patients who don't show
any symptoms in their statistics we know
there are thousands and thousands of
silent carriers and the Chinese
government says they are all under
quarantine but there are doubts about
that and yes but I think we can be sure
that now that people leave hue and also
the travel restrictions within the
country is that the numbers will go up
again
briefly China's been sending aid to
countries we're talking about face masks
equipment even medical experts is that
something Beijing plans to continue I'm
sure yes because this is also about
influence and also demonstrating in
their point of view that their system is
superior that they were able to defeat
the the virus and yes they really
prominently broadcast about it but we
cannot forget that also the European
Union also were was sending 50 tons of
medical equipment to China before but
yes it was not prominently broadcast
compared to what the Chinese are doing
now all right 5 en Kretchman reporting
for us from China thank you very much
South Korea is tightening border
controls after reporting a spike in
coronavirus cases and it's now enforcing
two-week quarantines on all passengers
arriving from the United States similar
quarantines had already been in place
for travelers from Europe so called
walkthrough testing stations have been
set up they're capable of more than 10
tests per hour
South Korea reported 146 new infections
in the last day 24 of those came from
Airport screenings still one news agency
reports the number of people who have
recovered from the virus has for the
first time exceeded the number of
quarantine patients all right let's
bring in Frank Smith now he is in South
Korea's capital Seoul frança South Korea
has reported an increase in new
infections we're hearing where exactly
are those infections coming from well
most of those infections are coming from
the southern city of Daegu in the
province of Yongsan that's where that
Shin janji that cult had a series of
meetings in early February and patient
number 31 really spread the virus to
hundreds of people there also as you
mentioned we're seeing an increase in
the number of arrivals coming into South
Korea's Incheon Airport bringing some
more cases into the country but again
most of the cases are surrounding Daegu
and
south central area of the country I mean
this is exactly what the South Korean
government and in fact many countries in
the region we're worried about right
where you made you contain the original
outbreak you flatten the curve and then
all of a sudden you start to see these
new hotspots sparking up again right
that's right we saw this with a call
center here in the South Korean capital
Seoul people are getting a little bit
complacent and they're not observing the
degree of social distancing that they
were before here in South Korea South
Korea hasn't implemented a complete
lockdown that we've seen in other cities
and in other countries but they have
engaged in an intense government sort of
PR campaign they've also said that
they're gonna charge people and they're
perhaps will be suits brought against
people that go out with the virus there
was a mother and daughter pair that
traveled around Jeju Island in South
Korea and spread the virus there and
they may be liable for a suit of up to
$100,000
South Korea is also implementing some
closures some parks were closed with
cherry blossom festivals coming in this
week the government is going to decide
what to do with schools there they're
set to reopen on April 6 but that's
likely going to be extended are there
still then enough encouraging signs do
you think in South Korea we've been
holding up South Korea as a success
story what do we make of the recent
number and numbers in how South Korea
has dealt with a pandemic well one thing
that's happened in the last couple of
days is well we've seen 10,000 cases now
more people more than about 5,000 have
been released after being cured of the
virus so that's a very positive sign
South Korea continues with its strong
testing and tracking measures which
include you know mobile applications
where you can see on your on your phone
where people have gone and where people
have contracted the virus but still it's
the social distancing campaign that the
government here is looking at and
looking to really more strictly enforce
all right correspondent Frank Smith
working for us from Seoul in South Korea
thank you very much